THE FORMER FIRST LADY, MICHELLE
OBAMA REVEALING SHE CONSIDERED
WEARING HER NATURAL HAIR AND
BRAIDS DURING HER TIME AT THE
WHITE HOUSE BUT DECIDED THAT
AMERICANS WEREN'T READY FOR HER
NATURAL BLACK HAIR.
LISTEN TO THE FORMER FIRST LADY.
>> AS BLACK WOMEN WE DEAL WITH
IT, THE WHOLE THING ABOUT DO YOU
SHOW UP WITH YOUR NATURAL HAIR.
BRAIDS, Y'ALL.
YOU KNOW, BUT WHAT -- YOU KNOW,
AS FIRST LADY, I DID NOT WEAR
BRAIDS.
BEING THE FIRST -- YEAH, WE HAD
TO EASE UP ON THE PEOPLE.
I THOUGHT ABOUT IT.
I WAS LIKE, IT WOULD BE EASIER.
NOPE, NOPE.
THEY'RE NOT READY.
>> THE FORMER FIRST LADY SAID
SHE KEPT HER HAIR STRIAIGHT SO
HER HUSBAND'S ADMINISTRATION
COULD FOCUS ON OTHER ISSUES, AND
NOT HER HAIR.
THE OBAMAS WERE COGNIZANT OF HOW
MUCH ATTENTION WAS PAID TO HOW
THEY LOOKED AND HOW THEY ACTED
BECAUSE THEY WERE BLACK.
THEY ALSO KNEW HOW POWERFUL
REPRESENTATION WAS AND STILL IS.
SO LIKE THIS MOMENT, THIS WAS IN
2009, WHEN A YOUNG BLACK BOY,
REACHED UP TO TOUCH THE
PRESIDENT'S HAIR.
>> I THINK THIS PICTURE EMBODIED
ONE OF THE HOPES THAT I HAVE HAD
WHEN I FIRST STARTED RUNNING FOR
OFFICE.
YOUNG PEOPLE, PARTICULARLY
AFRICAN AMERICAN PEOPLE, PEOPLE
OF COLOR, OUTSIDERS, FOLKS WHO
MAYBE DIDN'T ALWAYS FEEL LIKE
THEY BELONGED, THEY LOOK AT
THEMSELVES DIFFERENTLY TO SEE
THE PERSON WHO LOOKED LIKE THEM
IN THE OVAL OFFICE.
IT WOULD SPEAK TO BLACK KIDS AND
LATINO KIDS, GAY KIDS, YOUNG
GIRLS.
THEY COULD SEE THE WORLD OPEN UP
FOR THEM.
>>> LET'S TALK ABOUT THIS NOW.
CNN CONTRIBUTOR AND HOST OF
"NAKED WITH CARRY CHAMPION"
JOINS US.
HELLO TO YOU.
IT'S A THING FOR US, THIS WHOLE
HAIR THING.
I STRUGGLED WITH IT AS A KID.
I USED TO PROCESS MY HAIR, THE
BLOWOUT, IF YOU REMEMBER THAT, I
DON'T DO IT ANYMORE.
THIS IS MY HAIR.
BUT ESPECIALLY FOR BLACK WOMEN
IT'S A THING.
SO GETTING JOBS, PERCEPTION, AND
SO ON, SO YOU DEALT WITH THAT
I'M SURE WITH YOUR CAREER AND IN
YOUR PERSONAL LIFE OVER THE
YEARS, YOU RELATE TO WHAT
MICHELLE OBAMA IS SAYING?
>> THIS IS WHY WE LOVE MICHELLE.
BECAUSE VERY MUCH LIKE WHAT THE
PRESIDENT SAID WHEN THAT LITTLE
KID REACHED OUT TO TOUCH HIS
HAIR HE COULD RELATE TO WHO HE
WAS.
WHAT'S HAPPENING EVERY DAY.
WHEN I HEAR MICHELLE SAY THINGS
THAT RELATE TO ME AND THE LIFE I
LIVED.
WHEN I DECIDED I WANTED TO BE IN
TV, DON.
I WAS TOLD IN NO UNCERTAIN
TERMS, BY THE NEWS DIRECTOR WHO
HIRED ME, HOW WILL YOU WEAR YOUR
HEAR?
I REMEMBER IT LIKE IT WAS
YESTERDAY, IT WAS IN 2000, IT
WAS IN WEST VIRGINIA, AND I'M
LIKE, WOW, I'M GOING TO WEAR MY
HAIR HOW I WEAR MY HAIR, WHICH
IS NATURAL.
THIS IS NOT MY HAIR.
BUT MY HAIR, IF YOU WASH IT, IT
LOOKS LIKE IT COULD BE TEX
TEXTUREIZED.
YOU KNOW HOW IT IS.
PEOPLE CALL IT KINKY, WHATEVER
YOU WANT TO CALL IT.
SOMETIMES AMERICA, ESPECIALLY
FOR BLACK WOMEN, HAS MADE US
FEEL OUR HAIR IS UNACCEPTABLE.
SO WE STRAIGHTEN, PERM IT.
THIS ISN'T A UNIT, THIS ISN'T MY
HAIR, I'M NOT FOOLING ANYBODY.
BUT THIS HAS BEEN MORE
ACCEPTABLE.
AND SADLY I'VE GIVEN INTO THAT
IN MANY WAYS.
MUCH LIKE WHAT MICHELLE OBAMA
SAID.
SHE'S LIKE THE ADMINISTRATION
ISN'T READY.
REALLY?
IT'S JUST SO SAD, IT REALLY IS.
>> CAN I SHARE SOMETHING THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT LAST NIGHT WHEN WE
SPOKE ON THE PHONE.
>> SURE.
PLEASE, YES.
>> I CALLED KERRY AND I WANTED
HER TO DO THE SEGMENT BECAUSE I
KNOW THAT SHE'S DEALT WITH THIS,
I SAID WOULD YOU WEAR YOUR
NATURAL HAIR.
BUT IT'S A WHOLE THING.
IT'S EXPENSIVE, YOU HAVE TO UNDO
A LOT OF THINGS.
>> YES.
>> BUT ALSO, DO YOU WANT PEOPLE
TO SEE YOU THAT WAY?
IS THAT UNCOMFORTABLE FOR YOU?
>> YES.
DON CALLED ME, LADIES, HE CALLED
ME AND HE WAS LIKE, I HAVE AN
IDEA AND HE EXPLAINED WHAT HE
WANTED, I PAUSED FOR A SECOND,
LIKE IS HE SERIOUS RIGHT NOW?
WAIT.
DON'T YOU REMEMBER WHEN SO AND
SO DID IT --
>> TAMARA DID IT ON THE TODAY
SHOW YEARS AGO, YEAH.
>> I WAS LIKE, I DON'T RECALL.
I THINK I DO NOW, I WENT BACK TO
LOOK IT UP, OKAY.
UNDERNEATH MY HAIR IS BRAIDS.
MY HAIR IS BRAIDED ALL THE WAY
BACK, UNDERNEATH THIS HAIR IS MY
HAIR BRAIDED ALL THE WAY BACK.
I'VE TAKEN MY HAIR -- LITERALLY
TAKEN MY HAIR OFF IN THE MAKEUP
ROOM AT WORK AND YOU CAN SEE
EVERYONE LOOK, WHAT'S HAPPENING?
IT'S LIKE THEY'RE SHOCKED.
LIKE IT'S DISBELIEF.
AND THEN THE WHOLE CAN I TOUCH
YOUR HAIR IF YOU'RE NOT BLACK,
SO -- IT'S SO DRAINING POPPY, I
KNOW YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING.
IN THE SENSE THAT --
>> I DO.
>> AND SO I TOLD DON, NO.
I WAS TERRIFIED.
I DON'T WANT TO BE A MEME.
I WAS SO -- IT IS LIKE I WAS SO
TERRIFIED AT THE THOUGHT OF
SOMEONE SEEING ME IN MY NATURAL
HAIR AND I'M A GROWN WOMAN.
THAT IS SO SAD.
>> YOU'RE NOT ALONE.
I HAVE FAKE LITTLE CLIP INS THAT
I WEAR EVERY DAY.
AND DON SEES MY FAKE HAIR IN THE
MAKEUP ROOM.
>> I WANT SOME.
>> HOLD ON.
I DON'T WANT TO EQUATE.
THAT IS NOT TO SAY IT IS NOWHERE
NEAR WHAT BLACK WOMEN HAVE GONE
THROUGH WITH THEIR HAIR.
I'M TRYING TO TELL YOU, I HEAR
YOU, I FEEL SOMETIMES LIKE -- I
DON'T KNOW.
LIKE I HAVE TO PUT IT ON FOR
SOME REASON.
AND I'LL JUST TELL YOU, SIENA
COMES HOME FROM SCHOOL NOW AND
ONE OF OUR FAVORITE BOOKS IS
HAIR LOVE, I RECOMMEND EVERY
PARENT READ THIS WITH HER KIDS.
SHE SAID TO ME, WHEN SHE LEARNED
ABOUT -- LIKE ASK PERMISSION TO
TOUCH OTHER PEOPLE'S HAIR.
LEARNING ABOUT RESPECT.
>> THE THING ABOUT THAT, THOUGH,
DON TELL ME HOW YOU FEEL ABOUT
IT, I WOULD NEVER ASK TO TOUCH
ANYBODY'S HAIR.
I WOULDN'T.
I'M NOT FASCINATED TO WALK UP TO
YOU POPPY AND TOUCH YOUR -- OR I
WOULDN'T WANT TO WALK UP TO MY
COLLEAGUE THAT ISN'T BLACK AND
TOUCH THEIR HAIR.
THE FACT THAT BLACK WOMEN ARE
TREATED LIKE EXHIBITS IN A
MUSEUM, FOR LACK OF A BETTER
WORD, IT REALLY IS -- EVERY TIME
THAT HAPPENS WE'RE IN OUR MINDS
HERE WE GO AGAIN.
>> WE DID OFTEN OUR KIDS ARE
BEING TAUGHT THE WRONG LESSON
NOW.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
TEACH YOUR KID WE HAVE DIFFERENT
TEXTURE HAIR, IT'S THE SAME
THING.
IT STILL GROWS.
MAY NOT BE AS LONG, AS BLOND
NATURALLY.
IF YOU NOTICE THAT SOMEONE'S
HAIR MAY NOT SEEM LIKE IT'S
THEIR HAIR, PLEASE DON'T ASK
WHAT IS THAT ON YOUR HEAD.
HOW DO YOU WEAR YOUR HAIR?
EVERYONE WEARS EXTENSIONS.
FOR SOME REASON WHEN BLACK WOMEN
WEAR EXTENSIONS, IT'S LIKE
EVERYONE STOP AND TAKE A LOOK AT
THIS PERSON WHO IS AN EXHIBIT,
THEY HAVE LONG HAIR.
WHY IS THAT?
NONE OF THAT SHOULD BE A
CONVERSATION.
THERE'S A SONG, DO NOT TOUCH MY
HAIR.
LITERALLY, BUILT ON THE FACT
THAT THAT'S WHAT WOMEN HAVE
DEALT WITH, BLACK WOMEN
SPECIFICALLY.
>> I WANTED TO -- CAN I --
>> IT'S POWERFUL TO HEAR YOU
TALK ABOUT YOUR CONVERSATION
WITH DON SAYING YOU'RE A GROWN
WOMAN AND THIS IS HOW YOU FELT.
THAT'S WHY I THINK WE'RE SEEING
MICHELLE OBAMA BE SO CANDID AND
HEARING HER TALK ABOUT BEING
FIRST LADY AND SHE WAS WORRIED
ABOUT THAT.
IT OPENS UP THE CONVERSATION FOR
YOUNG WOMEN NOW TO BE ABLE TO
TALK ABOUT THAT AND THINK ABOUT
IT AND ACKNOWLEDGE IT
DIFFERENTLY, PUBLICLY.
>> I WILL SAY THIS, YOU MAKE A
GREAT POINT ABOUT THAT.
THERE ARE A LOT OF YOUNG WOMEN
ON TV NOW WEARING THEIR NATURAL
HAIR.
AND THEY HAVE GONE VIRAL FOR
WEARING THEIR NATURAL HAIR WHICH
IS TO ME, TWO THINGS, ONE, BOLD,
I'M NOT READY TO DO THAT, FOR
HER TO DO THAT IS BOLD.
BUT IT'S ALSO WHY AM I GOING
VIRAL FOR WEARING MY OWN HAIR?
I NEED YOU TO UNDERSTAND HOW
THIS IS AND WHY WE ARE SITTING
HERE BEING FASCINATED THAT IT
TOOK MICHELLE OBAMA TO TELL US
DON'T LOOK AT MY HAIR AS IF IT'S
WEIRD.
>> CARI QUICK BECAUSE WE HAVE TO
RUN.
IF YOU CAN DO IT QUICK, THIS IS
A LIGHTNING ROUND.
>> GO.
>> DO YOU THINK IT WOULD BE OKAY
NOW FOR -- FIVE YEARS OUT OF THE
WHITE HOUSE.
DO YOU THINK IT WOULD BE OKAY
NOW FOR HER TO WEAR HER NATURAL
HAIR?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> YOU THINK IT WOULD BE FINE?
>> OKAY.
>> I HOPE SHE DOES.
AND THEN I'LL DO THE SAME.
DON, I APPRECIATE YOU BEING
HONEST.
>> THE OTHER THING IS, CAN WE
START -- LOOK, I'M A MAN, I'M
SURE PEOPLE ARE GOING TO GET MAD
AT ME.
I LIKE NATURAL HAIR.
MY NIECES DO THE SAME THING,
THEY BRAID THEIR HAIR UP AND DO
THE SYSTEM AND WHATEVER.
ESPECIALLY IF THEY COME VISIT
WE'RE GOING TO BE AT THE BEACH,
THEY BRAID.
I LIKE NATURAL HAIR, CAN WE
BRING THAT BACK?
CAN WE BRING BACK THE POWER?
>> YOU KNOW WHAT, DON, YOU JUST
CHALLENGED ME, I'M NOT SAYING
WHEN I'M GOING TO DO IT BECAUSE
I GOT TO REALLY SIT WITH IT, I'M
TERRIFIED, LIKE I MENTIONED.
BUT WHY NOT?
I'M PRETTY I CAN WEAR MY NATURAL
HAIR.
>> YOU'RE GORGEOUS.
>> I REMEMBER PAM GREER AND
COFFEE AND CLEOPATRA JONES, THE
AFRO WAS BEAUTIFUL.
GET USED TO IT PEOPLE.
>> MY MOTHER WORE AN AFRO.
>> LET ME START IT.
LET ME BE GAME.
THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME COME
ON.
>> THAT'S WHY WE LOVE YOU SO
MUCH.
>> I'M NOT SPEAKING FOR YOU, I'M
SAYING THIS IS ME.
WEAR YOUR HAIR HOWEVER YOU WANT,
IT'S EASIER I KNOW IF YOU BRAID
IT AND PUT IT UP.
I THINK NATURAL HAIR IS
BEAUTIFUL.
>> WHAT A GIFT SHE IS.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.